so I posted a video a few days ago
where I said I shifted two times in a day
many people have asked how I did it
and let me tell you
it's actually really easy
so stop overcomplicate shifting
but what I did
so I had a really bad sleep
I almost couldn't sleep at all
I woke up
a few times
and when I woke up
I try to turn over and fall asleep again
but I immediately woke up again
so it was hard
so one time I woke up
it was early in the morning
I kind of just naturally
started laying in a comfortable position
and then starting my method out of nowhere
so I didn't plan to shift that night
but you know
I just did it
so what I did is I was doing the sunny method
I don't know if that's the full method
but it's basically
where you just focus on your surroundings
and you pretend that everything you hear
everything you feel
or you smell
is in Your Dr
You are in Your Dr
and You can feel the things around You
You can hear
maybe if your parents are allowed
then they're your parents in your Dr
or you know
you pretend everything you hear here
is in your Dr
and then I set my intention while doing that
so I was kind of
you know focusing on my surroundings
and then setting the intention
and then doing it again
and I didn't get symptoms or anything
it took me maybe 5min or 4min
so it wasn't long
so what I did is I
I kind of spontaneously
shifted to another reality
because I felt like
maybe that's going to be a bit easier for me
because my
favorite Dr
Is my harry potter Dr
right now
so I thought if I shifted to my victorious Dr
it's going to be easy
because I don't really
I'm not really excited about going there again
or I wasn't about going there the first time
so yeah and I shifted two times
because the first time
I shifted into a wrong reality
I didn't even open my eyes the first time
because it was too scary
I just heard a woman laughing
at the back of my head
so she was really near
and I could
she was hysterically laughing
it was scary
so I immediately shift the back
and open my eyes in this reality again
and then I thought
maybe it's going to be a bit less scary
so I shifted there again
and I again heard her voice and her laughing
but I stayed for a bit
so it was creepy
and I didn't plan
I don't even know who that woman is or was
I don't think
maybe it's andrew's grandma
I don't know
but yeah that's how I shifted
two times
it it was the same method
so the sunny
method and intention